le mouvement des chômeurs continue sa
pression robert heureux demandent une
augmentation des minima sociaux sur le
terrain les opérations se poursuivent au
procès papon le revirement d'un témoin
clé demain la cour d'assises entendra
michel bergès ce livre soit rien est à
l'origine de la faire à quelques jours
du voyage de jean paul ii à cuba les
qu'atelier que vivent leur foi au grand
jour après s'être caché pendant plus de
trente ans la découverte de l'école de
danse de nancy qui forment les jeunes
étoiles de demain des ballerines qui
rêve de faire partie du ballet national
cinéma avec la sortie de harry donc tous
les états le dernier woody allen film
jubilatoire à l'image de l'auteur woody
allen que nous découvrirons dans
l'intimité
chez ses parents à beaucoup madame
monsieur bonsoir au lendemain de la
manifestation nationale des chômeurs et
à quelques jours de l'intervention
télévisée de lionel jospin
le mouvement des sans emploi continue de
faire pression et tente de peser sur
l'hôtel matignon aujourd'hui occupation
encore d'une vingtaine de sites dans le
pays avec notamment à paris le bastion
qui est normale sup pour la première
fois une caméra pu filmer à l'intérieur
du bâtiment qui restera fermé pour
l'instant décision prise tout à l'heure
par le ministère de l'éducation
reportage
damien thévenot et jacques grégoire le
périmètre de sécurité est impressionnant
autour de normale sup crs policiers
empêchent toujours l'accès à l'école à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
une cinquantaine d'étudiants et de
chômeurs continue d'occuper les lieux
actuellement l'ambiance est très
détendue cyr
les chômeurs mange avec des élèves
nouveau tour
payet
puis j'ai à peu près normal nous à part
peu une partie de jeu de vente peut pas
sortir et rentrer même s'il est normal
inouïe nous balance un milliard alors
j'estime que ce four du en a marre des
ministres heures sup est occupé depuis
mercredi
même si une évacuation n'est pas
annoncer dans l'immédiat la direction
n'en écarte pas l'hypothèse ci à une
situation qui perdure et qui empêche
l'établissement de fonctionner je ne
vois pas comment on va pouvoir garder
des gens éternellement attire
d'établissement pour vous la situation
n'est plus tenable longtemps
non hier soir l'ambiance s'est
brusquement détérioré 19 heures la
grande manifestation parisienne est
terminée
des échauffourées éclatent alors entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre devant
normal su qu'elle te blessés légers chez
les manifestants
des animaux pour la pêche des animaux et
nous disait qu'il nous protège personne
ailleurs dans paris même colère même
ras-le-bol une méthode différente cette
fois c'est une grande brasserie
parisienne qu'une quarantaine de
chômeurs ont investi leur souhaite
manger gratuitement un verre ou pas
après une heure de négociations ils
obtiendront satisfaction à normale sup
comme dans une dizaine de sites encore
occupés en france on attend avec
impatience l'intervention du premier
ministre mercredi
on attend on espère les revendications
des chômeurs avec notamment
l'augmentation des minima sociaux
étaient bien au coeur de la
manifestation organisée par le parti
communiste cet après midi plusieurs
milliers de personnes à paris pour
réclamer un référendum sur l'euro avec
en tête robert hue reportage françoise
david dernier mériaux l'europe de
l'emploi
c'est seul que l'on fera la peur du
chômage encore et toujours présent dans
la manifestation organisée à paris à
l'initiative du parti communiste est
soutenu par le mouvement des citoyens
un cortège de militants hostiles à
l'europe de maastricht et qui réclame
d'un référendum sur le traité
d'amsterdam et l'euro car ceux qui
défilaient n'ont pas vraiment une haute
idée de l'europe qui se met en place
aujourd'hui ça va pas être retenu pour
ni pour les jeunes coureurs ni une
europe qui va causer un statut pour pour
les gens qui travaillent pour les
salariés et tous étaient vachement
inquiétant mais je n'ai pas envie de me
retrouver dans une europe où tout va
être déréglementé où j'aurai petite fête
du travail on va pouvoir m'embaucher
l'appartement on ne veut pas de cette
europe
on est en train de nous construire le
parti communiste se dit aujourd'hui
heureux constructive
il appelle de ses voeux une heure
pacifique démocratique et surtout
sociale mais pour en arriver là il faut
bien leur vernis passer outre les
contraintes européennes
j'en prendrais pour seul exemple celui
ci éclairant des réponses à apporter au
mouvement des chômeurs notamment
et ils sont nombreux les chômeurs avec
nous aujourd'hui notamment par une
augmentation significative des minima
sociaux et pour y répondre
car il faut répondre aux chômeurs il
faudra bien desserrer l'étau de la
marche alors lionel jospin devrait
recevoir dans le courant de la semaine
prochaine roberge
à cette occasion le secrétaire national
du parti communiste pourrait demander au
premier ministre de présenter devant le
parlement
un collectif budgétaire ce que les
petits budgétaire serait destinée
financer l'augmentation des minima
sociaux et voici qui nous amène à la
revendication martelait depuis plusieurs
semaines par les chômeurs le relèvement
immédiat de 1500 francs par mois des
minima sociaux un enjeu économique que
le gouvernement soumis aux contraintes
budgétaires dit ne pouvoir assumer même
en partie avant 1999
voyons maintenant concrètement ce que
signifierait pour un ré mist est un
salarié au smic
cette augmentation les explications de
thierry kurt et 1500 francs de plus tout
de suite et pour tout le monde c'est la
revendication des associations de
chômeurs depuis plusieurs jours
l'ensemble des minima sociaux concernent
trois millions trois cent cinquante
mille personnes dont un tiers touche
actuellement le rmi le revenu minimum
d'insertion est fixé à 2429 froid pour
un célibataire
comparé au smic c'est un 1300 francs
nets par mois
la différence est significative mais ou
rmi s'ajoutent suivant les cas et les
communes l'aide au logement
l'exonération de la taxe d'habitation la
gratuité des transports dans certaines
villes ainsi des économistes estiment
que rmistes qui retrouvent du travail au
smic ne va gagner que 1500 francs de
plus par mois
le rmi est l'une des aides les plus
basses l'allocation de parent isolé pour
les mères célibataires et de trois
milles 198 francs l'allocation pour
adultes handicapés qui touche de plus en
plus de monde et de 3471 francs
revaloriser l'ensemble des minima
sociaux 2500 francs reviendrait à
combler l'écart avec le smic et même
dans certains cas à le dépasser à lyon
le front national réuni pour présenter
ses candidats aux régionales de mars
prochain se veut comme un mouvement
soudée autour de jean marie le pen avec
une idée maîtresse le retour à l'ordre
reste que l'élaboration des listes et
des investitures a été l'occasion de
quelques règlements de compte
reportage à lyon michaël darmon patrick
desmulie 22 régions 22 candidats du fn
qui prétendent diriger les assemblées
régionales de la photo se fait en
famille à lyon
mais derrière les sourires les tensions
sont parfois vives au sein du parti de
jean marie le pen
ces derniers jours plusieurs
investitures était encore difficile à
boucler
beaucoup de personnes qui voudraient
être éligible confection des listes fait
forcément des ingrats et des mécontents
c'est toujours comme ça et c'est vrai
aussi dans notre partie parce que
maintenant il est comme tous les autres
partis politiques cherchent là c'est
dans le var que les dissensions sont les
plus fortes
eliane de la grosse conseiller général
et maire adjoint de toulon est en
conflit depuis plusieurs mois avec
jean-marie le chevallier son épouse elle
même candidate aux régionales
écarté des listes eliane de la grosse
d'y rester fidèle à le pen mais dénonce
la préférence familiale à toulon je suis
en colère car je trouve que notre thème
ma propre tête haute
peut être la première des choses à
conserver comme une relique
petit à petit j'ai très peur qu'elle
s'éloigne pour certains attention je
trouve anormal déjà que à coup un maire
sa femme adjoint alors qu'elles soient
aux régionales en plus c'est très très
bien placé je le dis carrément j'ai très
peur que ça ne soit pas bon pour tous
non comme toulon réagissent mal j'ai pas
le temps de me battre dit avoir
peut-être des nattes des personnalités
différentes et tout mais il n'y a pas
autre chose en tout cas qu'on a pas y'a
qu'un aucune concurrence mais il n'ya
pas que des mécontents et d'autres
responsables lepéniste parti en campagne
avec un objectif très précis à vendre
avant la corse chez que je dirais que
les gens qui évoque pour moi
chevron corp mois pour avoir quelque
chose d'une alliance entre les gens et
ce qu'ils doivent avoir mais pas que pas
choix cet après midi jean marie le pen a
clos les listes et rappelé son parti à
la discipline
puis dans son discours il a lancé le fn
dans la course en annonçant la défaite
de la droite quand on sait que l'une des
causes de ce bouleversement politique à
venir est la diabolisation du front
national on est en droit d'estimer que
l'on a affaire à la droite la plus bête
est la plus masochistes du monde
tant pis ils seront une fois de plus
totalement et exclusivement responsables
de leur défaite à lyon jean marie le pen
a renoué avec les fastes de ces réunions
électorales en poursuivant également son
objectif faire battre la droite
le pen président qui ces militants mais
ce que vivent aujourd'hui le chef du
front national c'est la présidence d'une
région aux assises de la gironde
témoignage très attendu demain de
l'historien michel bergès qui pourrait
faire basculer le procès papon cet
universitaire qui a découvert en 80 les
documents accusant papon et qui est donc
à l'origine de la sphère est passé
maintenant dans le camp de la défense
le revirement d'un témoignage françois
privat et philippe dumas nous avons
rencontré michel bergès au début du mois
de novembre
à l'époque cet historien et politologue
hésitaient encore à venir témoigner au
procès papon
même s'il affirmé détenir des
informations susceptibles d'apporter des
éléments nouveaux sur la responsabilité
de maurice papon certaines personnes ont
essayé si vous voulez de bon de lui
mettre sur le dos des opérations qui
n'avait pas fait on a dit qu'il a fait
déporter 1700 personnes
alors ça je peux pas l'accepter en tant
qu'historien mais j'ai pas dit qu'il n'a
rien fait il est au courant de rien si
vous voulez demain michel bergès viendra
à la barre cité par la défense de
maurice papon pourtant l'historien est à
l'origine de la découverte d'une partie
des documents qui accuse l'ancien
ministre
entre 1980 et 1988 il s'est battu aux
côtés de michel sites inscrits
pour obtenir le renvoi de maurice papon
aux assises son ancien compagnon
l'accusent d'avoir changé de camp
j'avais beaucoup de deux universités
pour vergès qui était à l'époque la caf
et la dignité qui avaient peu d'argent
ils m'ont fait toujours un franc pour
faire différent et en définitive il a
peut-être trouvé plus généreux que moi
où il a été acheté et il a changé son
fusil d'épaulé
aujourd'hui michel bergès se défend
d'avoir été achetée il explique son
revirement par la découverte de preuves
qui selon lui exemple et maurice papon
de toute responsabilité dans plusieurs
des déportations de juifs qui lui sont
reprochés il faudrait proposer sur
chaque document ce que n'a pas fait
l'arrêt de renvoi de la cour d'appel de
bordeaux
une théorie des signatures étant entendu
que maurice papon signe beaucoup de
documents mais qui n'est pas
nécessairement l'auteur d ordre et qu'il
ne gère pas l'ensemble des
responsabilités de ceux qui ont produit
des services qui ont produit ces
documents je fais mon devoir
d'historiens aime répéter michel bergès
au mois d'avril dernier il a rencontré
maurice papon à six reprises pour plus
de 16 heures d'entretiens années après
que des passants étaient et blessé par
balle ces derniers jours deux étudiants
ont été mises en examen et écrouées cet
après midi les jeunes gens auraient tiré
par simple jeu pour s'amuser reportage
olivier galzi emmanuel bec des traces de
balles encore visibles depuis quelques
jours cet immeuble était devenu l'une
des cibles d'étudiants leur axe de tir
la rue du général frère au bout tout au
bout dans une chambre universitaire
l'oeil rivé dans la lunette d'un 22 long
rifle derrière cette fenêtre
quelqu'un a tiré à plusieurs reprises
vendredi soir l'une des balles a
traversé l'abdomen d'une infirmière qui
passait par là et deux jours plus tôt
c'est un motocycliste qui avait été
touchée au poumon
j'ai entendu un bruit du coup de folie
vous savez à l'épaule gauche
auj je ne savais pas qui a tiré
résidence de castillon où habitait les
tireurs les étudiants se font discrets
ils ne veulent pas parler de leurs
camarades du quatrième étage
âgés de 20 et 23 ans l'un étudié la
médecine l'autre la biologie des jeunes
apparemment sans histoire seuls quelques
voisins nous ouvriront leurs portes
comme si votre voisin de palier car
était non pas du tout vous saviez qu'il
a une arme et qu'il tirait avec ça fait
bizarre que tirer sur les gens et tout
ça il y avait une bonne ambiance où on
se connaissait à peu près quand vous le
connaissiez non vous l'avez déjà vu
oui on se croit fort mais pas
personnellement quoi selon l'avocat de
la défense les étudiants ne visaient pas
des passants mais des lampadaires et des
poubelles
il s'agirait d'un accident quoi qu'il en
soit ce soir la chambre 484 restera vide
leurs occupants viennent d'être mises en
examen ils passeront la nuit en prison
à rome le pape jean paul 2 perturbé
amusé par des colombes aujourd'hui place
saint-pierre apparemment les colombes ne
souhaitait pas à quitter le rebord de la
fenêtre depuis laquelle le pape
bénissait les fidèles
par ailleurs au vatican le pape jean
paul ii a annoncé qu'il nommerait
officiellement va nouveaux cardinaux
lors d'un consistoire le 21 février
prochain
parmi eux l'archevêque de lyon jean
balan 63 ans qu'il a succédé il y a deux
ans et demi comme primat des gaules à
monseigneur de courtrai cette nomination
intervient quelques jours avant le
voyage de jean paul ii à cuba fidel
castro a d'ailleurs déclaré qu'il
assisterait lui même sur la place de la
révolution à la havane à la messe
célébrée par le saint père et il appelle
les cuma à venir en masse avec lui à la
prière une déclaration tout symbolique
puisque pendant plus de trente ans les
catholique de cuba n'ont pu vivre leur
foi au grand jour reportage dorothée
olliéric christian hutin
la vanne dernières capitales communiste
de l'occident avec ses rennes en ruine
et ses fantômes révolutionnaire pour
l'église
tout s'est arrêté en 1961 quand fidel
castro a ordonné aux catholiques de
choisir entre rome et moscou
ils étaient trois mille prêtres et
religieux il n'en reste aujourd'hui que
trois cents après la révolution le parti
communiste cubain impose l'éradication
des croyances l'état devient
officiellement athée et des dizaines
d'églises sont laissés à l'abandon
fermé ou reconvertis commission t as
avant la révolution plus de 70% de la
population se disaient catholiques
l'église et ses fidèles vont connaître
trois décennies de discrimination et
d'humiliation faudrait érigèrent un
monument au grand mère de cuba car ce
sont elles qui malgré tout et en secret
ont maintenu dans les foyers les
lumières de la fois pour exprimer
librement leur foi les cubains ont dû
attendre jusqu'en 91 avec l'effondrement
du bloc soviétique pour maintenir la
paix sociale
castro change de cap les croyants ne
sont plus hors la loi et c'est grâce à
cela que la famille lopez pour faire
baptiser la petite bérénice un baptême à
la chaîne dans l'église de la merced
c'est une responsabilité d'être pareil
j'accompagnerai ma fille dans ses études
dans sa formation je l'aiderai avec ses
parents les parents de bérénice ont été
baptisés il ya tout juste un mois
il n'y a pas si longtemps s'avouer
catholiques c'était risquer de se voir
interdire l'entrée à l'université se
voir refuser un emploi dans la religion
ils ont trouvé un espoir celui d'une vie
meilleure les revenus de la famille ne
dépasse pas 50 francs par mois le
salaire moyen à cuba j'espère que la
visite peuvent améliorer la situation et
mettre fin au blocus
en tout cas moi je prie tous les jours
pour la fin du blocus à cuba tous
attendent le pape les catholiques qui
espère que le salut viendra du ciel etc
à ce fonds qui compte bien gagner en
popularité
histoire de redorer le blason de la
révolution pour tous les catholiques qui
ont été opprimés pendant des années et
qui ne pouvaient pas vivre pleinement
leur religion la venue du pape à cuba
c'est un formidable cadeau de dieu de
dieu et pas seulement pour les
catholiques traditionnels la moitié des
cubains pratique la santeria very tout
se mêle croyances africaines et
mythologie chrétienne
le dimanche matin ils vont à la messe
l'après midi ils venaient d'autres
divinités comotion la déesse de l'amour
c'est cela aussi l'église cubaine
l'adami sur pied l'une des plus grandes
campagnes de vaccination du monde 40
millions d'enfants à travers tout le
pays sont en train de recevoir des
vaccins anti polio
il s'agit de la seconde phase de cette
opération de prévention destinée à des
enfants de tous les âges
l'amérique retient son souffle mais le
témoignage du président n'a pas varié
six heures de confrontation hier entre
bill clinton et paula jones qui poursuit
le président des états unis pour
harcèlement sexuel
les deux protagonistes sont repartis
comme ils étaient venus sous le feu des
caméras reportage maryse burgot river le
face à face entre bill clinton et paula
jones aura donc duré six heures et c'est
évidemment sans aucun commentaire que le
président américain qui hier soir en
limousine
le lieu de l'humiliante confrontation
pas plus de commentaire du côté de paula
jones qui elle suit les journalistes en
taxi cette jeune américaine accuse donc
le président américain de harcèlement
sexuel et après six heures de face à
face avec lui
elle laisse à son désormais célèbre
porte parole le soin d'expliquer à la
presse qu'elle ne peut rien dire
on saura donc seulement que tu que la
confrontation a été filmé la cassette
devrait être placé sous scellés jusqu au
procès fixée le 26 mai prochain à little
rock
si bill clinton décide de ne pas venir
témoigner au procès ce qu'il est en
droit de faire
elle sera diffusée aux jurés pour la
john sera donc laissé tous ses
journalistes sur leur faim pas de
déclaration à l'issue de la
confrontation mais l'on peut s'attendre
à quelques indiscrétions dans les jours
qui viennent
car comment garder le secret dans une
affaire
médiatique en angleterre les premières
images du petit jo le nouveau né est âgé
de deux mois sa mère lise bottle la mise
au monde à l'âge de 60 ans nous vous en
parlions il ya quelques jours pour la
première fois elle s'est exprimée devant
les caméras elle dit être en parfaite
santé elle et l'enfant ne pense pas son
âge mais accuse les médias d'être à
l'origine de la rupture d'avec le père
de l'enfant en france les modalités de
fermeture de superphénix devrait être
rendue publique la semaine prochaine
la décision de définitivement cesser
l'activité du surgénérateur avait été
prise dès juin dernier une décision
politique qui sortent maintenant à la
mise en chantier de ce démantèlement que
les scientifiques n'avaient pas imaginé
les travaux sont plus importants et plus
compliqué que prévu
reste aussi à régler la reconversion
économique et social du site et de sa
région
l'enquète de josée longchamps à pierre
et patrick voix c'est ainsi depuis dix
ans cet ingénieur franchi les grilles de
superphénix pour retrouver sa famille sa
maison qu'il a bientôt fini de payer la
fermeture de la centrale ils ne
l'acceptent pas surtout que selon lui la
décision est politique et qu'en fait
c'est la filière nucléaire qui est visé
je suis très fier travailler à super
phénix parce que j'ai vraiment
l'impression j'ai même la condition de
travailler pour les générations futures
pour mes enfants pour mes petits enfants
pour moi quand je serai très vieux et il
n'est pas le seul dans la région à
s'opposer à l'abandon de la centrale
élus en tête c'est la majorité de la
population qui défilent pour défendre
son outil de travail et préserver
l'emploi ce gérant d'entreprise qui
travaillent pour le compte de
superphénix a pris la tête de la
contestation
d'après lui rien n'oblige à fermer la
centrale tout de suite on pourrait
l'utiliser en outil de recherche la
prolonger d'une dizaine d'années comme
beaucoup d'autres prestataires ce qu'ils
demandent c'est un délai le temps de se
retourner
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est comment de
mars
si on en interne à 100 par le phénix mon
entreprise de sampans dépôt de bilan
mais ça sera blessé en première année
sera en cessation d'activité
faut le faire morestel 3000 habitants un
supplice travaille à la centrale
la commune est l'une des plus riches du
département et d'après une enquête
effectuée auprès des commerçants fermer
l'usiné nucléaires entraînerait une
baisse d'activité des 50%
si vous prenez les opticiens au niveau
national vous prenez une liste de 3000
habitants il n'y a pas de petits chiens
vous prenez m'en restait les huit de
3000 habitants nous avons en
ophtalmologie sts nous avons deux
opticiens
donc j'aime raison c'est qu'à la
clientèle il y a vingt ans ces tracteurs
étaient des premières manifestations
tail gate opposants à la construction
aujourd'hui même s'il est difficile
d'être anti nucléaires dans la région
certains ne voient que le bon côté de la
fermeture annoncée la fermeture de
superphénix ne sera pas brutal
on va pas dire demain super phénix est
finie 1500 personnes dehors c'est pas
vrai puisque le démantèlement d'ailleurs
en a bien eu tout démantèlement
d'ailleurs ce plan technique était même
pas prévu donc il faut déjà le concevoir
ça prend un certain temps ce soir là le
maire de morestel recevait les deux
inspecteurs du gouvernement chargé d'une
étude sur le sort de la centrale
c'est aussi leur avis la fermeture du
surgénérateur prendra une dizaine
d'années première étape qui
commenceraient début 99 et pourrait
durer 18 mois
l'évacuation du combustible
on transfère son stockage en piscine
deuxième étape vider la cuve de ses 5000
tonnes de sodium ici en orange ce fluide
radioactifs qui s'enflamme au contact de
l'air devant ensuite être désactivée
dans une usine à construire sur place
l'opération est délicate elle devrait
s'étendre sur plusieurs années
produire plus de plutonium qu'il n'en
consommait c'était la vocation de ce
prototype mais contrairement aux
prévisions
ce combustible ne manquent pas le
surgénérateur n'a donc plus de rôle à
jouer 60 milliards de francs trois ans
de fonctionnement sur onze années
d'existence c'est le bilan de celle qui
devait être une super centrale le rallye
paris dakar a pris fin sur les bords du
lac rose les français peterhansel pour
les motos et jean-pierre fontenay pour
les autos ont remporté la 20e édition du
rallye les meilleurs moments de cette
compétition qui s'est déroulée sur dix
mille kilomètres
florent gautreau le motard vainqueur
s'est arrêtée c'est au tour des larmes
de rouler sur le visage raviné par 18
jours d'efforts des larmes salées lac
rose oblige pour stéphane peterhansel
vainqueur du dakar pour la sixième fois
record absolu une première en revanche
côté voitures la victoire de jean-pierre
fontenay une consécration attendue pour
l'ancien mécano
voir dakar et sourire le rêve de tous
les concurrents les une réalité pour
seulement 104 équipage sur 370 sur
départ on a beaucoup chuté on s'est pas
mal embourbé bref tradition respectée le
20e dakar a été sans pitié et ceux à qui
le sable n'avait pas suffi ont trouvé le
moyen de boire la tasse en arrivant à
saint louis dernière frayeur avant le
bonheur de dakar des chutes le dakar des
galères le dakar des colères aussi jps
l'afrique et son humour l'afrique et ses
couleurs le dakar c'est aussi du bonheur
maroc mali mauritanie sénégal
dix mille kilomètres de sable de
cailloux et de latérite
vingt ans après rien n'a changé la
traversée est plus folle plus belle et
plus improbable que jamais
le ballet national de nancy fête ses 20
ans au programme le lac des cygnes
découverte du spectacle à travers
l'école de danse de nancy et des rêves
des ballerines jérôme soûlard patrice
sous ma chère l'école du travail et de
la graph des petites filles a piqué sous
les yeux des mamans dans ce lieu de
magie où les contes de fées se produise
quelque fois
des années d'exercice à la barre pour
rêver d'un passage au milieu des étoiles
tient dans ces écoles parce que la danse
classique c'est un peu plus prêt
gracieux en r&d beaux costumes aussi et
puis la musique est belle grande musique
et petits pas avant l'envol des
ballerines tchaikovski le lac des cygnes
anniversaire romantique d'une
institution du classique
grands et petits fait aujourd'hui le 20e
anniversaire du ballet national
le monde a besoin de rêver nous avons
des problèmes dans la vie lorsqu'on
vient dans un théâtre
si pour oublier ses problèmes c'est pour
justement assouvir les rêves que nous
avons envie de faire et vous voyez ce
qui est fantastique j'ai vu le lac des
cygnes à 10 ans j'ai 20 ans 66 ans je
suis toujours aussi émerveillé j'ai la
même émotion
l'émotion d'une soirée très spéciale
la grande salle de l'opéra pour
stéphanie g son rêve du bout des yeux
c'est bien la magie du ballet romantique
qui en coulisse permet même quelques
fois au petit rat d'embrasser son étoile
marine castel princesse de nancy tu veux
en faire vraiment un métier alors oui ça
te plait vraiment c'est que c'est très
très difficile mais si tu aimes vraiment
ça il faut le faire alors
décor chorégraphies et costumes fidèle à
la tradition centenaire du lac des
cygnes
le ballet de lorraine ouvre une belle
page de sa nouvelle histoire une
histoire de danse une histoire d'amour
cinéma avec la sortie de harry dans tous
ses états sans doute l'un des films les
plus réussis de woody allen l'histoire
d'un écrivain en panne d'inspiration que
traverse pour notre plus grand plaisir
des mimes ou robin williams
woody allen en toute liberté reportage
parce qu'elle défend philippe deslandes
s'ils arrivent en enfer c'est qu'il
n'est pas vraiment le compagnon que vous
souhaiteriez à vos vieux jours
écrivain célèbre il aime l'alcool les
tranquillisants et les femmes les
siennes
il en a il faisait froid mais pas
seulement fait étonnant qu'il soit dans
tous ses états au point de faire le
bilan de relatif mais fois brillant de
son existence tout et [ __ ] ça le prix
d'affaires je veux que tu souffres qu'en
dit si tu sais que je n'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi la fusée
intelligente des femmes n'est pas
capable de faire la différence entre une
insignifiante passion sexuelle à retorde
et le confortable train train d'un beau
mariage solide
il y voit seulement s'il a été la salle
aussi en a eu d'autres
noémie pona catella sommet puisse dieu
me foudroyé sur place si je pense tu es
un athée harry oui et on est tout seul
dans l'univers du même responsable
donc c'est pas étonnant non plus car ils
en faire de son latorre et deviennent
tout flou vous dis allah nous offrant
alors l'une de ces géniales 10 déc
cinéma dont il a le secret
au début on vous passe à l'action
tu fais pas par lui pourquoi je sais pas
enfin la plupart des clients elle ne pas
sauter directory sans parler un peu il
trouve que ça fait trop commercial mois
et coûté quelques noms célèbres ont
accepté une drastique réduction de
salaire pour être de l'aventuré vous
avez deux secondes pour en reconnaître
jeu léché et le public rit beaucoup
aussi une fois de plus car depuis 32 ans
et autant de films nous dit le décalé a
su nous fait rire de notre propre biopic
je vous propose maintenant ce document
woody allen dans l'intimité grâce à un
prochain film consacré à sa tournée
européenne de jazz qui sortira le 11
février prochain woody allen chez ses
parents presque centenaire à brooklyn
des dialogues vous allez voir sur le vif
dans la pure tradition du signalement
maintenant pour avoir tous voient pas
ils sont également
jacques gamblin acteurs qui a fait
parler de lui au moment de la sortie de
[ __ ] douce nouvel exercice pour cet
artiste très doué seul en scène le
toucher de la rance une histoire de la
valse à la gaîté montparnasse reportage
caroline laudrin d'idées dans le
maintien du coup c'est du miel noir je
lui ai pris la main on a survolé partir
de là on a rattrapé le temps perdu on
est rentré là dedans comme si c'était
celle ou caleçon c'est l'histoire d'un à
charmer un mordu qui grâce à la valse à
donner un sens à sa vie
pour ceux qui ne savent pas la valse
c'est toute une histoire avant de la
raconter
jacques gamblin un peu il a observé les
coûts plus admiré leur aisance et mais
leur complicité d'un soir
et alors avec des mots il tente de
raconter ce qui fait d'une étreinte
un moment magique
avec les mots arrivé à retraduire faire
ce travail absolument impossible
impossible de trouver les mots justes
pour dire qu'est ce que ça vous fait
dans le corps quand dans ses caisses que
ça fait au corps qu'elle commence à ce
rappel c'est impossible je la conduis tu
la prends mais tu vas tiens tu me tiens
c'est haram c'est une cour où une valse
mais pour ce soit toujours trop court
une masse ne faut pas seulement une
bonne tourneuse faut qu'elles inspirent
des jambes et les siennes mais ça
tricote ça se faufile sa caresse partys
sa survie le salon dissipe le danger sa
effleure le sens jacques gamblin aime
surprendre
bien loin du strip tease de [ __ ] douce
on le retrouve seul sur scène dans un
monologue d'une heure laval se mettent à
leur performance du comédien le talent
de l'écrivain
si je monte sur scène en solo et si
j'écris des textes et que je les joue
c'est pas pour ça c'est pas parce que je
joue pas du travail par ailleurs c'est
simplement parce que c'est encore là une
nécessité dix panneaux paso-doble comme
dans ce même si je voyais une corrida en
une heure vous avez fait le tour de tous
les bals vous connaissez tous des
qualités d'une bonne chaussure à
l'entretien et bien d'un parquet mais
surtout vous avez ses connaissances avec
un être attachant un peu fragile
excessif un homme qui sait aussi faire
valser les mots et tourbillonner les
idées
deuxième jour des défilés haute couture
à paris aujourd'hui la collection
givenchy ungaro pour le printemps-été
81,18 là s'était s'agi le second joue la
carte de l'inattendu reportage nicole
cornu langlois et patrick descheemaecker
du raffinement de la rigueur de la
sensualité
le jeune fauve se serait-il apprivoiser
à 27 ans un an après son entrée en
couture chez givenchy alexander mcqueen
a mis de côté son agressivité et peut
être compris que la femme avait besoin
d'être habillé et regarder d'une façon
plus tendre il faut apprendre très vite
bas on est vraiment cerner par les
requins encore de la provocation bien
sûr mais une mode plus sereine plus
fluide des modèles qui suggère plus
qu'il ne révèle un style très dépouillée
quelles sont les conditions idéales pour
votre inspiration sommet d'une colline
en angleterre avec juste au dessus les
arbres et les oiseaux et surtout 200
personnes cette solitude vous est
propice alexander c'est votre collection
la plus réussie depuis votre arrivée en
france
curieusement c'est avec emmanuel né
garraud que l'on entre dans un monde
futuriste avec des bustiers de métal
argent mais bien sûr avec des dentelles
et broderies du passé et du présent
depuis sa première collection en 1963 ce
grand couturier travaille dans la même
ambiance
le silence mais la musique abyss silence
évidemment et surtout c'est la ss de
discipline très forte
je n'avais presque militaire dans la
rigueur par rapport au travail par
rapport à cet acharnement à trouver
véritablement cette ses formes ses
formes là qui sont dans dans mes rêves
ce n'est pas mal d'émotions de
sentiments de poésie et tout ça doit
faire un discours cohérent et c'est de
dire comme comment dire c'est toujours
en fait le maire mit à des vents
nouveaux sociétaires là tout comme
fellini réaliser toujours le même film
et que flaubert écrivait le même livre
emmanuel ungaro décline la même
séduction à chaque saison
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres le
mouvement des chômeurs continue sa
pression robert hue redemande une
augmentation du linas sociaux sur le
terrain les opérations se poursuivent au
procès papon le revirement d'un témoin
clé demain la cour d'assises entendra
michel bergès l'historien qui est à
l'origine de la faire tout de suite la
météo présentée par isabelle martinez
puis à 20h50 à très bons films la
poursuite impitoyable avec jane fonda
marlon brando et robert redford demain à
7h50 dans les 4 vérités françoise
laborde recevra ségolène royal demain
soir vous retrouverez à cette même place
daniel bilalian je vous remercie de
votre attention bonsoir